[Music]
this month i read every single chapter
of chainsaw men and today i'm delivering
my final thoughts on this series through
my coverage of the final three arcs to
tell you the truth when i first started
this series three weeks ago i truly did
not know what to expect there was hype
surrounding it for sure but there have
been plenty of those in the past that
never really floated my boat which is a
nightmare when you're a review channel
with that said this story was different
where i've struggled to keep reading in
the past with other series chainsaw man
offered fascination and clever twists
where other series have been let down by
clunky paneling this one soared higher
than very few i've ever seen come before
i've made a habit of comparing this
manga and its production to many others
across this series but to tell you the
truth while standing on the shoulders of
those that have come before it chainsaw
man manages to innovate and create for
me an adventure and experience that's
unlike anything i've seen before to say
that i'm excited for the anime to drop
later this year would be the
understatement of a lifetime and here's
why this is my review of the harrowing
unrestrained and blood-curdling
disasterpiece penned by none other than
tatsuki fujimoto this my friends is
chainsaw man
[Music]
the international assassins arc
before i started this series i said to
myself that i'd make four videos however
i am now glad that last week i decided
to make just one more because of the
last three arcs that remain this next
one it might be the one i enjoyed the
least in this series this isn't to say
of course it didn't have some brilliant
moments some great story development and
some super popular car
it absolutely has all of those things
with plenty of implications for the
future that help to drive the next and
final two arcs into the stratosphere so
why didn't this arc work for me as well
as it might have done for any of you
guys watching well from chatting with
one of my editors who loves this arc
they told me that not only is this held
in massively high regard amongst the
fanbase but was in fact a period of the
story that really grabbed a lot of
readers attention and i can see why the
format itself is very simple following
the now famous chainsaw man as the
agency he works for is tasked with
protecting him from the newly introduced
assassins from the different corners of
the globe i like the idea behind this
personally as it does have a lot of
upsides it helps to broaden the scope
and the implications of the plot to a
global level it helps build up the world
more and as i mentioned it's simple
which is honestly kind of nice however
it's with that last aspect of the story
that i noticed my first and honestly
most pressing issue arose the arc itself
spans across two full volumes making it
one of the longer arcs of the series of
those two volumes i really enjoyed the
second one or the second half of the
story it's where the vast majority of
the plot happens and develops however
within the first half i felt as though
the pacing of the story screeched to a
halt the premise of an international
effort to assassinate the chainsaw man
is a compelling one and on its face a
seemingly fun story to follow however in
exchange for that clear and concise
format we're all too familiar with the
story itself loses a lot of the
spontaneity that i've loved about the
chainsaw man series since i began
reading it it sets up a number of
different families agencies and
mercenaries for hire from different
countries all vying for dengi's heart
this is interesting and carries with it
a lot of expository heavy lifting
however in exchange this means that the
narrative also becomes rather
predictable and bogged down during this
section by having to tell us who these
people are and why they are the way that
they are and their motivations etc which
in any other story would be perfectly
reasonable i've just gotten used to
chainsaw and leveraging the reader's
expectations more to deliver surprise
after surprise and this one just felt
very
i wouldn't say boring but it did feel a
lot more safe by comparison my favorite
part of chainsawman has always been
getting to spend time with the central
cast power aki denji mahima and even
some of the other secondary characters
are very well established and tons of
the hijinks and humor stems from their
interactions and misadventures within
the ordinary and the extraordinary
however in the first half of this arc it
felt as though they played significantly
smaller roles all in an effort to
facilitate the exposition for characters
that ultimately die in this very arc
with all of that said however once that
half was completed and the pieces
finally started to fall into place i
felt my interest in reading this picked
back up tenfold with the midpoint twist
acting as the catalyst for all of this
specifically when i read that
conversation between kanshi and kishibe
and saw that kishibe really didn't trust
makima i knew we were in for something
special and oh boy
were we turning the weirdness dial up to
11 chainsaw man once again reached its
stride hurling denji and the gang into
literal hell during this section you
could really tell the fujimoto was
making a concerted effort to illustrate
and convey the horror elements of this
story wherever he could and not just
through traditional avenues like
monsters but through existential dread
he really comes across like a student of
horror in this section as a result
introducing us to the primal fear devils
through the darkness devil himself was a
fascinating visually surprising and
gruesome experience with that shot of
the astronauts sliced in half and lined
up being a hauntingly grotesque yet
beautiful reminder of how damn talented
this manga cut truly is the descent into
hell was one of the most surreal
feelings of powerlessness this series
has ever forced me to contend with
watching on as all the people we've
grown close to over the last number of
arcs are tortured and mutilated to
terrifying degrees made for some of the
most compelling reading i've enjoyed in
a while and that's not even to make
mention of makima's involvement she is
not only a powerful devil it seems as
though that she is the devil to look out
for in this story and i didn't even
notice this the first time i read it but
another wonderful easter egg my editor
pointed out to me after i finished the
story came from that very torture scene
where all of their limbs are
disconnected from their bodies so to
speak the limbs themselves spell out
something
how [ __ ] cool is that the action and
combat scenarios in this arc are quite
different too with the newly introduced
assassins acting as an elegant vehicle
to facilitate unusual encounters the
brothers from the usa created a
momentary dissension amidst the group
not to mention the power of the
bodyguards at denji's disposal which
come into prominence in later arcs the
santa claus dude created effectively an
army of zombie dolls out of the citizens
in the area another brilliantly horrific
visual that leverages the strengths of
the genre and of course the giant demon
doll girl there's a tremendous level of
progression in this arc second half
teaching us tons about the world why all
the devils have a fascination with the
chainsaw devil himself and perhaps where
this story might be going in the not so
distant future looking at this arc from
an analytical perspective was
interesting i wondered if perhaps the
weekly nature these chapters were
released and digested helped to add
intrigue and encourage the building of
the story i wondered if the arc felt
like a natural jumping on point for a
lot of new readers thus expanding the
community immensely regardless i think
you'll all agree that the way i first
read through this story was quite
different to how many of you long-time
fans of the series did and i think
therein lies my personal problem and our
difference perhaps where you guys were
allowed to bond and turn the car into a
meme when my editor asked me about it i
legitimately didn't remember the car at
all because i had already finished the
series i suppose it goes to show that
the manner with which you view or read
something very much colors your
perspective on it later but in a
nutshell i had described this story in
the past as one that's driven heavily by
its central cast of characters and when
they take a backseat to this degree
particularly in the first half it felt
that little bit less like chainsaw men
to me while i was reading overall
however when i take everything about
this arc into consideration there's
still a ton to enjoy particularly in its
second half with halloween machine
halloween the darkness devils santa
claus and halloween halloween halloween
halloween
halloween
did you know that the car i didn't even
remember managed to rank higher than
kobani in the popularity polls i'm
actually serious halloween the gun devil
arc
the final two arcs of chainsaw man are
in my view the strongest of the series
and as close as this series gets too
perfect as many of you i'm sure are
aware at this point i'm very much the
type of person that values the journey
far more than the destination itself
however even i will admit that it seems
to be easier to write some brilliant
stuff early on when you don't have any
restraints compared to tying those
various plot points together at the end
when your story needs to meet its
resolution in a satisfying manner the
merits and cohesion of your story is
laid to bear and if things don't work
then those plot threads snap and to see
that you need look no further than hbo's
game of thrones as an example of such a
catastrophe as soon as the showrunners
were required to write their own
material to bring everything together
without the proper time care and
understanding of what ought to be done
with these established characters the
show to put it politely imploded on
itself leaving the vast majority of fans
feeling empty this is all to say that
when your character-driven story has
clearly been building up to something
significant for it not only to live up
to those expectations it's set for
itself but to over deliver is indeed a
rare outcome for sure something i
personally worry about tremendously for
the likes of one piece but one i can say
chainsaw man delivers on in spades
kicking things off i really enjoyed this
chapter entitled bath these are the
chapters that chainsaw man does best in
my opinion and ironically it's not
really to do with the intimate nature of
the events that take place within them
but instead what sort of introspection
that stems from those intimate scenes
across this whole story denji has in an
effort to achieve his dreams and live
the most fulfilling life possible
actually started to show signs that he's
growing as a person he's making the less
desirable choices when faced with
dilemmas because they are the
compassionate thing to do
and in doing so manages to highlight for
us the good he can potentially bring to
the world and how these actions can help
even the most reprehensible or selfish
of individuals to grow and mature as
people in the first couple of arcs denji
felt like a child someone that didn't
know what intimacy was or why he was
feeling a particular way about anything
however now he's able to make inferences
based on his understanding of the world
and his past relationships he's able to
understand that his platonic feelings
towards power are more closely akin to
an older brother instead helping her to
deal with trauma she's experiencing
following the climax of the previous arc
with the darkness devil similarly aki
someone who i had characterized as being
the polar opposite of denji in that he
didn't care if he led a fulfilling life
as long as he killed a gun devil has
transformed into someone that wishes to
withdraw both himself and his division
from this mission because now he feels
like his life has meaning beyond that
mission he has something to lose now
something he values
he has a family if the last ark
delivered anything that was worthwhile
it was the beginning of this arc proper
following that all too close brush with
death being faced with utter darkness
forevermore it seems the three main
characters in this story have grown
tremendously from it despite their scars
and to back up for a second this arc is
remarkably short given the title the gun
devil arc however the title itself is in
effect a misdirection as the main
driving force behind the story is
anchored by the fondness and closeness
the group of aki denji and power grow to
feel for one another and how that is
stressed and strained by the true
subject of this story
when confronted by makima about his
desire to withdraw himself as well as
denji and power from consideration aki's
life comes crashing down far beyond what
he thought was even possible as makima
manipulates him with ease into rejoining
by leveraging her control over both
power and denji in the gun devil
assignment with aki's only recourse
available to him being to beg makame for
mercy and to give her anything she wants
to assure her that denji and power will
be safe and this is where the story goes
[ __ ] crazy in the best of ways makima
reveals that the gun devil is
neutralized and that the main objective
now is to seize control over as much of
the remaining parts of said devil to
assure japan's safety into the future
with that sort of acting as a metaphor
for the nuclear deterrent in accordance
with mutually assured destruction and
that's what this story has been about
ever since the beginning manipulation
and control fitting as makima is the
controlled devil and therefore the
greatest threat to global security
leading the us to launch the gun devil
into action killing as many people as
they deem reasonable to get to makima
it's funny that the extreme means with
which the usa elected to launch an
attack on makima and japan indirectly
feels the very control makima has over
people with her leveraging the prior
attacks to manipulate aki and help her
to legitimize the agency she fights for
in the first place the circumstances are
necessarily circular which is honestly
the most unsettling part of this entire
story with paranoia being the order of
the day one cannot exist without the
other each one fueling the supposed
justifications they have to attack which
brings us to the conclusion of this arc
and as i mentioned it's a short story
but it packs one hell of a strong gut
punch at the end
there's so much achieved in such a short
amount of time in this arc all the while
leaving space for one of the most
beautifully handled battles i've ever
seen committed to the pages of any
shonen and i mean that prior to this
attack's launch when consulted the
future devil reveals to aki that denji
will in fact slaughter both he and power
and due to this aki was willing to do
anything in his power to survive and
protect both of them even give himself
to makima but
makima has other plans resulting in
this is comfortably one of the top three
moments of the series for me and might
even be my favorite and the manner with
which it's depicted is not only novel
but
harrowing to sit and read through
earlier in the story the future devil
promised us that aki would die in the
most horrible of ways imaginable a death
so bad that even the future devil
himself wanted a front row seat to see
it and in much the same way a story
promises you a satisfying conclusion
this claim promised us a worthwhile end
for aki's character and it didn't
disappoint having become a gun fiend aki
entranced returns to his home where
denji and power lie in wait fearful of
what lay behind that door the fight that
ensues contrasts tenderly and fiercely
in equal measure with the last moment in
aki's life he was truly happy his
present happiness violently clashes with
his past happiness manifesting this
horrid delusion that forces him to
attack the people he's given everything
to protect but i think what made this
fight all the more special to me was its
conclusion denji forced to kill his best
friend someone who was like an older
brother to him while he aki or what's
left of his consciousness understands
the interaction to be a childhood
snowball fight the very snowball fight
that he never got to experience or share
with his brother prior to the gun
devil's last attack symbolizing at least
in this one perfect moment that aki very
much saw denji as a brother too and that
could fill the void that traumatic event
left in
[Music]
it's only nine chapters long but this
gun devil arc was nothing short of
spectacular to read through and one of
the shining achievements of this
wonderful series
control devil arc in an interview
conducted in 2017 fujimoto himself said
this about korean films that i think
signaled exactly what he chose to do
with the chainsaw man's story he said
i've always wanted to write a manga
that's like a korean movie there's this
movie called the chaser where the main
character chases after the villain but
30 minutes into the movie he catches him
this is supposed to happen at the end of
the movie so you keep wondering what
will happen next a lot of people say
that in korean movies they can't tell
what the director is thinking but
actually if you watch until the very end
you'll get it the main plot of this
story we've been led to believe was the
pursuit and termination of the quote gun
devil and just as we're heading into
what we feel should be the climax
fujimoto had the gall to title that last
arc the gun devil arc and then switch
the antagonistic target of the series on
us in the last seconds and it works so
damn well following those events for the
first time in denji's life he's grieving
and he doesn't understand these feelings
at all from the beginning of this series
he's undergone a significant and rather
nuanced change with his maturity and
outlook on life wherein the more he
understands and contends with the more
his world expands the more nuanced each
encounter becomes and therefore the more
consideration and mental anguish he has
to agonize over we've watched him change
from someone that honestly didn't know
if he cared at all about humanity to
someone that found a dream he thought
was worth fighting for all the way to
the man that wanted to do anything but
pull the trigger or in this case rev the
chainsaw to achieve that dream he was
never a monster a devil or anything so
uncaring towards humans he was just a
lost boy that grew up without someone to
guide him and so now he's having a
full-blown existential crisis in other
words we've seen denji develop and grow
as a character the boy that would eat
literal vomit now can't even stomach a
fresh treat due to the grief he feels
these are all super interesting and new
developments in this story for the young
character and just as he's trying to
process these feelings fujimoto brings
the story back to the oppressive formula
that's unconsciously dragged denji down
this path of sorrow and destruction he
brings makima back into the picture in
true deform she brings him home to her
place gets him integrated and boom she
says that he's earned his reward the
reward that carried with it an
uncompromisingly heavy price and instead
of what he initially thought he wanted
once again denji reverts back to being a
child he doesn't want all of this
responsibility in maturity because it
can be difficult sometimes too difficult
and so to alleviate himself of that
difficulty he gives himself up to makima
and throughout this tale also while aki
and power were strong forces that helped
to socialize and mature dengue
effectively makima around every turn has
thrown roadblock after roadblock in
front of his development forcing denji
to make choices that he otherwise
wouldn't have made without being pushed
in said direction this has been the
through line or main narrative thread
that spanned across this entire story
genji's grappling with doing the right
things
[Music]
this is the single most screwed up thing
i think this already messed up manga
forces me to sit and watch after
relinquishing himself to makima she
invites overpower and
bang
as here we see the consequences of such
action no matter how badly denji might
wish for this to be a dream or for
himself to stop thinking he can't this
is real and these are the consequences
he's brought unto himself the image of
this door has been ominously looming
over the series whether it be via dreams
visual manifestations or indeed
the deaths of his two best friends both
doors that opened and either directly or
indirectly he caused he can't stop
fighting he can't surrender control he
has the power to change things and every
second he doesn't he's making a mistake
[Music]
the final battle is paced extremely well
with the major set pieces spread out
perfectly to help hold audiences
attentions it's strange but the way
chainsaw man is illustrated and laid out
it almost feels like a storyboard for a
film sometimes particularly during
action sequences i haven't read dragon
ball super in a while but something i
didn't like about it once upon a time
was how much the action in the action
manga felt like filler and due to that i
think chainsaw man feels at least on
some level like a modern critique of
shonen action manga within each fight of
this series fighting doesn't just happen
for the sake of ending an arc or a
conflict fights occur in the story when
they have to happen when they believably
should occur and this is the most
important part once they do occur they
service the story being told in
fascinating ways the story doesn't just
stop to show the fight it continues
because of it scenes like denji slicing
through hell and makima afterwards his
pit stop at kobani's family restaurant
and days with kobani are all very
different ingredients that go into
making this wonderful meal of a fight
scene for us to enjoy also on a visual
front this is some really smooth
interesting paneling and artwork there
are some really sweet page spreads atop
rooftops with some really satisfying
perspective shots as we zoom in and zoom
out of the action however at this point
i will say that i wasn't in love with
the way power exited the story it felt
rather i don't know unceremonious
particularly compared to aki that was
until fujimoto decided to surprise me by
having the little blood of powers in
dengi's system act as a means for her to
come back momentarily she literally
explodes forth from denji's collapsed
body screeching about being the first
president and that makima is trash first
of all based secondly i'm really happy
that the harrowing but short scene where
power was taken from denji wasn't
power's last hurrah she is one of the
most overly dramatic dynamic abrasive
and funny characters in the series and
for her to go out following an act where
she became a shadow of herself would
have been i mean all right i guess but i
love that fujimoto chose to do this
instead choosing not to end power's
stint in the series with a demure
whimper but instead an appropriately
powerful chaotic and defiant final
battle cry that managed to shift the
podium in favor of denji if not only for
a moment she's been an active character
from the very beginning of the story and
despite her having grown tremendously
since the introduction she's still
capable of extraordinary feats that
catch even the despicable machine off
guard there's tremendous amounts of back
and forth to take place in this final
section and while i've been reading
online some folks found that it was a
little rushed i can't say that i agree
or at least not in the same way that
perhaps many of you might be feeling in
a 2017 interview talking when questioned
about what he thought of the theme of
revenge fujimoto had this to say i think
what matters most in revenge is how it
ends and also what the main character
will do once his revenge is accomplished
denji by the time this story ends has
been manipulated and controlled by
makima into killing two of the people
closest to him in the world power and
aki and you think the most interesting
part of this story would have been the
final battle between he and makima to
liberate the world from her looming
presence and and while this might not
necessarily have a lot to do with
revenge specifically i think the focus
that fujimoto places on what happens
afterwards to the character speaks a lot
about this particular quote as i think
it's wonderfully true to the character
and direction that denji's beheading
chainsaw man is and always has been a
story about where one finds the resolve
and meaning in life to push onwards from
a troubled child that struggled to
survive alongside pochita to one that
felt obligated to define his own dream
ending with a snapshot of a much more
mature character having gained enough
experience to not act irrationally when
faced with someone that could
potentially do tremendous harm in the
future after dengi's final take out of
makima was accomplished he didn't let
his memory or experience of her control
him beyond the grave instead choosing to
see the little girl for what she is
someone in need of guidance and health
and overall i think chainsaw man if
nothing else should be remembered for
its commitment to stay true to these
characters that in my opinion greater
than the gore world visuals or weirdness
made this manga a more than worthwhile
read on a number of levels many stories
often if allowed enough time failed to
deliver and ground their characters in
believable ways i mentioned game of
thrones earlier and daenerys targaryen
fits that building unfortunately while
the destination she ultimately lands on
isn't unreasonable to think for her
character to land on eventually with
enough time and care the writers of that
particular show instead rushed the
development of that character for no
other reason than their wanting to end
the show there and then fujimoto on the
other hand had delivered the exact
opposite of this by conceiving of and
delivering upon the conclusions for all
of the main characters in this story
that believably brought them a full
circle conclusion and in doing so
managed to serve the story greatly the
fashion with which aki finally makes a
contract is the logical conclusion of
all the events that took place since he
was introduced power started as an
uncaring sociopath convinced that she
had no one in this world that she could
love and ultimately manage to believably
sacrifice herself for denji the person
that she does love earlier in this video
i mentioned that chainsaw man in many
ways is a modern critique of older
actions shown in tropes and nowhere is
that more obviously seen than through
the character of denji and his
development as a main character he
doesn't yearn to be the best devil
hunter there ever was like the way luffy
wants to be the pirate king and many
others might in different shows instead
he's a regular albeit impoverished young
man that just wants to lead the best
life he can an intentionally ambiguous
goal the definition of which changes as
denji does throughout this story and
that's sort of the point chainsaw man is
a manga that i not only recommend but
encourage all even show a passing
interest in japanese storytelling be it
through anime or manga to pick up and
try for themselves it's easily one of
the most consistently exciting and
thrilling reads i've ever had the
opportunity to sit down and enjoy and i
cannot wait to see what the anime has in
store for us later this year and what
part two has in store this summer next
week my team is taking a much needed
break i might still drop something
myself but if i do it'll probably be
something a little weird so prepare
yourselves for that either way i hope
you enjoyed this video pick up your
chainsaw man inspired merch through the
link in the description and thank you
all so much for watching